et le tout le monde sait ce que je
trouve pour l'épisode 3 de the last
guardian
voilà je me suis échauffé pour cette un
trou et on va baisser d'un ton tout de
suite on peut donc maintenant donner des
ordres à tricot comme on l'a vu à la fin
de la vidéo dernière alors j'ai fait mes
petites recherches en fait faut monter
entre ses deux cornes comme ça pour
qu'ils obéissent aux ordres
voilà où alors c'est une coïncidence
fois aux phases i thought tu avais tu as
vu tu peux sauter voilà il l'a vu hélas
il va sauter dessus tu souhaites là vous
savez pas là je voulais aller merci mon
pote c'est adorable voilà du coup ça va
autant inouï les crédits ni senti qu'on
doit aux nazis autres les coûts n'ont
aucune attache au team est ici a dit ça
casse tout à coup ils masi oka rhône et
où ils trient coup nous racontons up
match est il aussi à l'horizon c'est la
folie monia donc dû tourner un moteur à
anti ceylan et et à leur aaa le fameux
levier au regard et à l'alcool dans
l'épisode 2 up met du poids à quoi sert
cette grille exactions iam bouffe il est
en bas et ce qui peut sauter là non il
pourra pas on va tester on va sans doute
voir ce qui va le faire au delà
non il va le faire je pense qu'il va
juste posé ses pattes de manière ce que
j'aille le chercher
ouais c'est ça j'arrive mon gars tu es
un petit peu de temps à réagir qu'on me
donne un homme mais c'est normal
hop allez mange le bal a du coup on va
pouvoir au choix c'est plus violent
qu'on ait fait de toutes les deux être
couverts et jcp mal enfin me fait mal je
boite non c'est bon on va sauter mon
grand bien allez allez
ne montre pas ton cul à tapas manger le
vidéo encore c'est ça tu attend sagement
tricot ait déjà déjà contrôler tant que
je te plaît donc en fait j'ai une grosse
bêtise de vue de la vidéo il n'y a pas
besoin d'être entre ses cornes pour lui
donner d'ordres s'est totalement une
bêtise il faut juste en fait relâcher à
rennes fois que j'ai donné la passion je
veux dire allez on va sauter tu l'as vu
ouais coup l'espoir d'accrocher ses
bombes a dit tu peux y aller j'étais
persuadé qu'il allait faire sauver qu'on
allait s'envoler quoi défunt sans lui
tombé dans le vide ayem petite escale et
là tu l'as vue il est là l'escalier
c'est bien c'est bien merci c'est à peu
près ça c'est à peu près ça reste comme
ça c'est un peu c'est pas mal c'est pas
mal on a un bon début et là c'est bon
c'est passé merci tricot tu m'as fait
plaisir et envoie du rêve mon jeu mon
chat germond jamais fois je me ferai pas
avoir alors on est au dessus est ce
qu'on va pouvoir lui ouvrir non ça je
rappelle qu'on cherche toujours l'autre
cris commun c'est ouf de l'avoir de thé
le boycottage et qu'on n'a pas assez
d'un lien qui veut toujours plus bas ça
m'a juste amener à au dessus il ya un
trou ça ouais je pense
et là on se faufile là dedans vous
pensez oui au premier conduit comprend
de tout je joue pas enfin non on avait
pris un remarque avant l'apparition des
armures alors du coup on est dedans ou
faut qu'on aille maintenant ça les
questions sans mourir c'est vrai ça
qu'on se pose des questions
vas-y lâche-toi up alors au bout là bas
je crois que c'est un levier foyen bruit
une musique qui met la pression lors les
dés d'accord il ya des armures en bas et
des serrures embarrassé des sentinelles
le problème c'est que la tricot peut pas
passer en plus donc si je tombe je tombe
quoi adacore gardenia-1 le vif juste là
à temps c'est un levier ou c'est la
chaîne qui se tient en haute mer de cet
auteur si je descends je me casse je me
casser en deux intéressant sa part un
petit peu en infiltration à homme on va
avancer
moi je pense qu'il faut descendre là
ouais mais là je vais mais je me
tracasse si je descends maintenant
j'aimerais juste voir si c'est un levier
normal ou c'est une chaîne à sinsheim je
crois à mon avis de façon fin décembre
est une façon qui ne tente rien n'a rien
comme on l'a vu au des rapideaux à la
valeur après la mecque ces violences
qu'est ce que ce qui s'est pris à wels
ah bon en tout cas nous on pas repéré ok
là je suis prêt alors on va attendre ça
fait ça met la pression mais qu'un on
n'a jamais fait donc j'ai peur qu'on
soit je sais pas à quel est le rayon de
vision du truc je le colle d'aussi près
que je peux je pense en faire griller ok
ce parti on a très peu de temps à les
tricots
c'est boyer la hoya c
ah les migrants d'asie duran duran duran
tu rentres
tu pas cela
il a dit tu passes
yes
fire pas tant que c'est dû retirer ok
c'est bon ok ça va chier
il va aller défoncer je vais le casser
pour le calmer et tout va bien se passer
basset fine et ja happ house c'est bien
mon grand on a géré la tous les deux
mois le taf ait fait aplatir par la
porte parce que je me suis fait chier
dessus devant l'armure mais voilà je me
suis auto pays donc du coup c'est bien
ce que je pensais le deuxième levier on
va devoir lui demander de se lever pour
pouvoir y accéder
non mais laissez moi j'ai pas ta force
mon gars moi je peux mourir en 2 demain
plaint pas attention à toi quand même
voilà à c'est trop cool depuis qu'on
peut donner des heures je trouve ça plus
intéressant encore quoi il ya beaucoup
plus de mécanique c'est pas juste au
monde dessus pour voir si fait quelque
chose c'est à nous de le guider
là clairement c'est à nous de le guider
à on va passer là dedans les petits
pieds petits pieds nus à bonal on a un
gros plan le fait est que ça m'avance à
quoi faire ça finalement je suppose que
je dois faire le tour allez on n'a pas
peur du vide des tas de gens font ça
tous les jours
hop passe avec je me demande quand est
ce qu'on va recroiser le tage et que
certaines depuis qu'on a eu le deuxième
trio j'ai que ça en tête mon gars à le
trouver la piste est en train de rater
le trou best of interpretation sexuelle
de ce que je dis y'a de quoi faire entre
la dernière fois au moulias c'est abusé
alors du coup j'ai atterri en eau
assayag haut des airs des armures je
suis dans un autre hall donc tricot et
derrière la porte qui est juste là en
fait alors sauf que cette fois il y en a
trois enfin réfléchir away qui en plus
se croiser comme ça sachant que quand je
vais sauter génie aulas a beau plein
dedans allez parfait
allez en plus en plus ghb cas c'est bien
bel et bien parler quand je peux faire à
temps peut-être si je les emmène au bout
non ils vont trop vite
j'aurais jamais et si je fais ça et
ouais mon pote comment tu vas me choper
là c'est quoi ça y est waouh
et puis allez maintenant man on man on
man on man on n'aura jamais autant vas-y
tricot
aux jo ce pas c'est patrick au waf à la
mémoire à la même voie là on herbe au
d'accord j'ai un passage en dessous
comment ces fourbes personne ne l'avait
vu celui-là lé doit se dire ma vie mais
où est le petit air est bon pote êtes
pas mal égard la visite
tp je te tutoie avant qu'ils arrivent à
les couvrir est bloquée au c'est
tellement bon j'ai pas pu exploiter
courir ça allez on reprend il arrive là
je sens qu'ils arrivent mais on va
ouvrir la porte à tricot qui va bien
s'énerver
lescott est coincé pour toi voilà je te
laisse les exploser aller 2-1 aller au
petit deuxième quand tu peux faire trois
d'un coup la e lyco problème chat perché
et va envoyer des sorts lui qu'on a je
penchais retricoter mois
et ses côtés fait allez vas-y défonce
les voilà il tombe dans le vide à la
grosse merde ça c'est fait alors ensuite
à bas pour refaire pareil c'est ça on va
accéder aux dérivés du couderc la porte
lie l espèce de truc qu'on a fait tomber
dans le vide tout à l'heure on dirait
merci mon tricot petites caresses
bah ouais faut remercier quand même je
vais bien alors on passe de l'autre côté
et maintenant il ya plus de garde
j'espère oui à ce truc là là je me
demande ce que c'est
abba levier simplement
ok sa batterie qu on va descendre par
ici et là mon gars allez c'est parti
du coup qu'est ce que c'est que ça je
jette dans le vide encore il faut que je
le tire vers moi à il a peur de ça il
aime pas ça d'accord moi je vais
d'ailleurs qu'est-ce que ça fout la
pierre lys à l'assemblée je vais de
leurs de sauter allez vas-y tu peux le
faire
alors on y va parfait montmaur ça va tu
tiens à remercier mon pote il me met
direct le premier j'avais même pas vu
qui va se passer au fouet merci tekoa
qui après j'aurais pas dû sauter
j'aurais dû sauter là bas avec lui je
n'ai vu que je suis combat mec j'ai fois
rien bon à un moment j'ai foi j'ai foi
il faut je fais du cacao icco
je suis choquée beau à l'ellipse on se
retrouve au du caillou ok donc cette
fois au lieu de sauter à pieds je vais
dire de galles et à l'asie c'est bon il
va dépasser petites ailes aux quellier
zazie tata le pont par la tricot ouais
tu te retournes et tulle atteindre là où
tu peux vous on était assez grand à ces
pièces il n'a pas peur ce tir allait oui
mais pour leur indiquer de sauter saute
pas aidé je vais rester accrochés alors
là je dis assez bon y va il va il est
chaud allez on est parti yes yes
week-end au japon et attention je vais
tomber
ok c'est bon
et ben voilà nouvelles zones on est bien
là tricot alors il va mon pote et il y
avait raillé what the fuck
il ya des rails et on est du coup il ya
une grille moi je peux passer vite pas
on se refera pas avoir à cause d'une
grille a trait à la guerre on peut
passer rien ouais donc pas d'accord en
fait c'est comme une chatière g j'avais
pas vu la donne la preuve qu'il a fait
ça ah bah voilà le petit crochet on a
trouvé une date pour la solution de
sortie
allez on y va non mais je pars avec tu
m'en empêche c'est un vrai chat lui 1
maintenant il se fout de ma gueule
j'ai compris et vas-y joue avec je vais
y accéder rock pourtant dessus parce que
j'ai la chaîne c'est mon rêve sur la
chaîne joue pas avec moi un truc sinon
ça va être très très violent comme ce
que je me trompe il ya ta les câlins
alors on est en hauteur qui sont à
parfaire du coup depuis l'automne à un
petit levier très bien ça je me lève pas
bien conservée à 6 voilà
torch en haut de la tour il va être
attirés par la lumière
ouais à temps j'arrive à y aller ok donc
qu'il est attiré par les flambeaux c'est
noté on commence à bien grapel t'as vu
ça tricot tu veux faire des trucs d'où
d'ailleurs aller j'y vais à la truite
moment où j'avais par là moi je passe tu
peux me suivre non c'est un peu étroit
pour toi
il ya plein de feu ici c'est trop
content c'était devenu avec mon tricot
ok j'ai cru que c'était pas ça que faire
vraiment j'ai eu très très peur et
ensuite foncé sur la cage est monté la
chaîne non en fait faut que je descende
ou simplement je suis jamais venu ici à
faire le tour par là haut pour que je
vois très bien où vous voulez en venir
et ensuite par là hop là voilà et
ensuite on peut se laisser tomber tel un
train de péter un câble tricot découlant
de vie devient fou c'est qu'est ce que
c'est que ça a c'est de la potion qui le
rend dingue ça c'est la potion 2e des
répits zod qu'il rend complètement ouf
c'est totalement ça c'est bon tout va
bien
théo tricot à thé juste là à bagnères
levier ni plus ni moins tâche toujours
pas récupéré le bouclier sais je sais
bien je la prenne avec lui amène comment
je vais faire pour lui amener à une
grille alors c'est bon je l'ait
peut-être qu'il faut remonter donc on va
remonter à mon avis je crois qu'en plus
c'est ce qu'il faut faire
alors attends ça s'ouvre est bien
d'accord que ça s'ouvre ce cas là
ouais ok à mon avis il faut le prendre
et le suspens de crochets cayla de base
que tricot arrêtait pas de remuer claque
c'est ça si en le poussant ça va activer
le mécanisme
ouais c'est ça ok parfait elle le prend
dans la gueule carrément nice
parfait attention
jacques ces petits garçons et petites
filles procède pas pourquoi il va finir
microscopique peuvent être tout à ça que
ça sert à quelque chose
ouais bon je fais monter je vois pas
trop ça peut nous ça peut mener et
pourquoi pas
ok ça faut le mettre là ça pourrait du
coup je suppose top à quelque chose
toute la ve plus bouger et je comprends
pas à quoi il sert en plus a ainsi ok
faut que je tire maintenant sur le côté
c'est ça d'accord j'avais pas vu ma le
pouce et par l'autre côté en fait je
pense qu'on va devoir bloquer la porte
avec ça c'est sûr hop on est bon on est
et on continue de montgrand white nerfs
se choisit encore un coup de poing coups
oui c'est bon c'est bloqué c'est bon
allez tu viens voilà allez tu manges on
ne joue pas avec la nourriture tricot
les images le mans je mange de tricot
avant qu'on bouge tient bon et force bon
tu vois qu'on est forcé coup droit à ça
y est apte à y aller puis t'as vu ta
connerie 1 on ne met jamais un bon
burger de côté c'est un programme que
j'ai inventé il ya une seconde
voilà maintenant on y va et bim et n'a
pas fait ou la merde c'est un piège
c'est quoi il faudra pas passer entre
césar
autour d'eux
ok vols ont été ou allah qui inhalent
aussi auto l'icône quelques-uns qu'est
ce qui est à césar c'est quoi ça assez
des morceaux d'armure ok donc je dois
l'ex take des morceaux d'armure et les
mettre à côté des miroirs ça d'accord
attend le casque d or die fait pas ce
qu'on veut sans déconner non plus de
muscle au coût que les biceps et comment
ça va mieux quand je les casses tu t'en
mieux pourquoi il a peur de ces miroirs
[ __ ] j'ai envie d'en savoir plus comme
les espèces de cristaux bleus à qui
l'avait rendu ou fois j'ai envie de
savoir ce que c'est on est bon avec ont
fouillé les pouilles allez on y va
alors on gagne en hauteur franchement en
fait ouais on est pas mal du tout on va
descendre qu'est ce qu'on à la fin d'été
les wallace a l'air compliqué là what
the fuck en plus le miroir il est
protégé donc je peux pas le cas c'est
avec un vase alors c'est quoi la
mécanique quatre spéciales à faire il ya
un truc spécial à faire mon petit doigt
me dit ok je peux l'avancé
à sa tombe
parfait ça dégage ou aux puces au dessus
tout derrière fais toi
tout est là dans ton petit monde là je
vais dire de venir je sais pas ça va
résister à son poids b
merde saute au tricot
lago et du coup on fait comment bah
ouais on est comme des cons comment on
fait tu viens me chercher
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire sotchi te
rattrape hockey
oh shit
merci tricot c'est un coup de poker
je commence à parler un peu le le tricot
l'âge qui est le langage de tricot faut
dégager ça un plongeoir fait pour
accéder à ce truc et à libérer du tricot
ouais ouais bah ouais bah up
enfin je le tire mais ça à m'embarquer
non je vais faire le tour s plus prudent
alors qu'est ce que ça va casser cette
fois sa tombe
je pense que ça va rien a marqué sept
fois sa tombe way qui ont fait au
complet
tu me regardes
ajoutons
auquel centre à tomber je suis là
oh merde
là que là que la grosse que l'ago skrela
grosse que de tricot oui je pense qu'en
ce moment je suis accroché je pense que
je suis accroché paquet
vas-y go
je suis là je lâche il a tant fait pas
je suis là
oh
c'est le petit caux
[Musique]
ce que je dois faire
adecco vas-y que je te caches tu casses
je suis passé le moment mais il est dans
le mal là comment je peux t'aider quand
je peux t'aider
comment je peux t'aider à c'est ça si je
m'étais d'alex harvey etien saisi le
tronc saisi le truc vas-y tu cette
saisie le 16 il saisit le vas-y vas-y
oui c'est bon oh [ __ ] je marche à toi
vite avant que tu partes en moi et que
tu m'abandonnes savent que je ne puisse
dire au revoir
les gens vivent au liban liban dimanche
cette dépêche ramon très grave
[Musique]
et bien voir les abysses et déjà peint
ce troisième épisode de cela square
garden de le dernier jardin mais c'est
pas là mais ça vous a plu
énorme kifle à ce petit total wipeout
version tricot il a assuré je peux te
dire que j'ai envie d'en savoir plus sur
l'histoire pourquoi couper l espèce de
gardien tant de questions qui restent
sans réponse que nous en saurons très
vite dans le quatrième épisode à la
grenade au camping la tuque sont trompés
pis pardon
[Musique]